the latest apex trailer teases season 5
and there are a lot of important details
you might have missed let's break down
the biggest reveals in the trailer
season 5 called fortunes Faber brings
lobha into the fray
we already got her origin story from a
previous trailer her father was
assassinated by revenant and she's been
looking for revenge ever since the new
trailer shows us the end of her search
she enters a facility where we actually
learned some new revenant lore revenant
is not just one killer robot every time
he dies his consciousness gets uploaded
to a new body hence why he's so hard to
kill that consciousness comes from the
original assassins head which is mounted
in a facility beneath Kings Canyon Lobo
has come here to destroy the head
defeating revenant once and for all
she's actually using the same gun that
revenant wielded when he attacked her
family but she fails and revenant is
teleported to another facility however
her time in the facility seems to hint
at her abilities though respawn hasn't
announced what those are just yet in the
trailer we see her throw a disk and
teleport to its location this happens
when she first enters the facility
though we've seen examples of this in
previous trailers Lobos endgame
appearance on the lobby screen and a
world's edge Easter Egg we also see Lobo
use her staff to pull a gun from a
guards hand into hers Lobo also fights
off the guards using the staff so
perhaps that's also in ability enhanced
melee hits would be an interesting way
to spice up the Battle Royale the
facility itself is destroyed by the end
of the trailer and it looks to have
formed a lake where skull town currently
stands in Kings Canyon that's notable
for two reasons first new seasons have
always brought map changes to Apex so
the loss of an entire facility is
significant and may play into the quest
hinted at on season 5s main page second
it ties into the seasons split ranked
series just like season 4 fortunes favor
will have two separate series for ranked
matches they'll kick off in Kings Canyon
with the new season then shift back to
world's edge in June season 5 begins on
ps4 Xbox one and PC on May 12th we'll
have confirmation on Lola's abilities by
then so stay tuned a game spot for a
closer look at the new Legend
you
[Music]